what a reveal you you become data again
right everybody thought it was a goodbye
yeah that was it well I've died twice
you know uh and and very likely will
again at some point not in episode I
mean were you surprised did you know all
along oh well I knew I I mean the Terry
metallis who uh wrote and show her in
the the and directed the last two
episodes uh you know we we talked about
it before we started can we do this can
I get away with this how do I do this
because data is different
when you see them again it's a different
data wow yeah was it cool to play yeah
it was it was it was like really can I
pull this off because he is different
he's um he's not he's he's you know
there was a thing Roddenberry I'll say
this really really briefly but from the
very beginning Rod Mary said uh here's
what I want from data I want him to get
as The Show Goes On get closer and
closer and closer to being human and by
the end still not and that continues
along this thing because he's much much
closer to human but still not wow